auch die inzidenz die zahlen die da
immer genannt worden sind
die sind gewürfelt tut mir leid da gibt
es keine wissenschaftliche basis für gar
nicht wer würde das aus am ende muss man
wahrscheinlich die politik aus würfeln
wer sich also ich weiss nicht erzählen
dass sie auch herr drosten oder
irgendwelche anderen wissenschaftler
also irgendeine art gewürfelt und die
politik hat daneben übernommen denn
dafür ob so ein 50 warum sagen will ich
45 53 also da ist irgendein wert nicht
wichtig irgendwas brauchen wir dann
geben wir dann das fest machen
eigentlich schade denn ich habe auch
langsam zweifel dass dass wir überhaupt
auf den völlig falschen dampfer sind und
zb gucken wie die intensivstation an da
da hör mir nun seit einigen tagen
eigentlich gar nichts mehr und die
intensivstation die ich echt überblick
ja weil die in einer zuständigkeit sind
die sind nicht überfüllt die sind gut
gefüllt aber wir mussten noch nie
irgendjemanden verlegen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren